one of the great shortcomings of society  is people have lost their ability to be  uncomfortable so much of what you're  seeing in today's society is we've  demonized the ability to have adversity  discomfort in our bodies having a  contentious meeting that you're like  frustrated again learning how to  synthesize that in your stomach and then  put it on the shelf and still be able to  go out and have a good day and still not  be scared that you're gonna get fired  learning how to convert adversity  discomfort  pain  judgment negativity and convert it in  your science project of your soul to  something positive like this is patience  this is positive adversity this is a  learning experience this is a great  story one day to laugh about  that's my [ __ ] superpower and it's  the one that i want to impose into the  world